powerful storm building in the southeast
threatens to make it a whole lot harder
for more than 76 million of us to travel
this Christmas heavy rains and strong
winds are expected to cause widespread
flight delays and the highway flooding
that storm will affect the Northeast by
tomorrow triple-a is now predicting that
more than 112 million Americans will
travel by road air or train between now
and the end of the year it could take
four times longer than usual for drivers
to get through major US cities david
regno is on the George Washington Bridge
that connects New York City with New
Jersey David good morning beyond a good
morning just starting across the bridge
right now did you know today is the
worst day to travel this holiday season
and more people are going to be
traveling by car than really any other
means of transportation in fact 102
million Americans are expected to travel
by car that's about one third of all of
us it's the highest number counted since
triple-a started tracking that stuff
back in 2001 so get a load of this more
than six and a half million people are
gonna fly across the nation this year
that's a 15 year high and when it comes
to driving triple-a says the increase on
holiday road travel is due to two things
really there's a rise in disposable
income but also the national gas price
average has dropped pretty significantly
here are the numbers according to
triple-a the national gas price average
is down 53 cents over the last two
months some people say it's really
plummeted and it's expected to drop to
two dollars and 35 cents per gallon by
Christmas days so if you time it right
and if you go to the great gas station
and that is the secret here you could
save between 10 and 20 dollars every
time you tank up your vehicle if you're
planning to hit the road today look it's
the worst day to travel but the best
time we're told to get on the road is
3:30 this afternoon the beg knows are
not traveling what are the Dickerson's
doing John the Dickerson's are going to
try to fight through an airport on
Saturday but if we could have the kind
of sunrise you're experiencing we would
be taking the road
nicely done thank you David